Hey guys, I'm Raymond Wong, product analyst with Mashable,...
...and today we're gonna check out the Samsung Gear 360,...
...a new 360-degree camera that lets you capture your own VR content.
Samsung's already got the Gear VR headset...
...and now it's got a VR camera to go along with it.
The Gear 360 is a tiny ball-shaped camera that fits in the palm of your hand.
The splashproof camera has two fish-eye lenses...
...that each capture video in 195 degrees.
The videos are then stitched together into a 360-degree video...
...using the power of the Galaxy S7.
360-degree videos are saved to a micro SD card...
...and can be wirelessly transferred to a Galaxy S7 smartphone...
...for editing and sharing to Facebook, YouTube, etc.
Final videos have a resolution of 3840 x 1920,...
...and in my opinion, look quite good.